So, Michael, I wanted to thank you again for coming in today.
I had a chance to review your resume,
and I was actually quite impressed.
So, you have a background in accounting and you've actually
transition doing more autonomous systems type work recently.
Yes.
So, there's one project in particular be really interested in hearing about,
which was using convolutional neural nets in self-driving cars.
I was wondering if you wouldn't mind taking me through a little bit of that project,
some of the challenges that you faced,
some of the methods that you used and if there's
anything that you would have liked to have done
that you just didn't have a chance to yet.
Sure. So, in that project,
I was originally attempting to come up with a deep learning approach that was more
robust than what we had done in the class around advanced lane finding.
So, in the project,
we had used more classic computer vision techniques,
where we use different colored gradients, et cetera,
to go through and find where the ley lines like they were in the image,
then we had to do perspective transformations,
where we essentially got a bird's eye view of the road.
All this took quite a bit of computational power,
so it wasn't really real time.
I believe it was running at roughly three FPS or so,
which doesn't really work in real-world applications.
You're not updating fast enough.
So, in this approach, I wanted to get something that truly could
go at real speed around 30 FPS or so,
as well as being more robust than what I did before.
The original one wasn't very good on curves for instance.
Once they got up to too big of a curve,
the algorithm just would stop working,
and run off the page essentially,
and think that the lines were going straight when they're really going curved.
So, along with gathering that training data then,
which I went out in the sense you just drove around my car.
I had my phone up and taking in
video images and extracting those frames out from my training data.
I then moved on to my network.
My network was built using a similar architecture to SegNet,
which was a paper I read at the time.
I'm putting it into a diagram it out here.
Yeah. Could you show me that really quick?
I'm not really familiar with that one.
So, SegNet's basic idea,
it starts out like a normal convolutional neural network.
Usually, a convolutional neural network comes out
with an input image coming in as your input.
Then, you have successive layers that are smaller convolutional layers.
A lot of times in another network,
you might have a fully connected layer at this point.
But the difference with a fully convolutional neural network,
which is what SegNet had in it was that on the flip side,
you come back with what are called D-convolutional layers that
solely get larger and have this semantic output,
where it potentially is the same size.
Your imagery could resize it back up to that.
But every single pixel in that output is actually a different class.
In my case, it was whether you were the lane, or not the lane.
So, in doing so,
then I'm basically doing binary classification between the two.
There's also applications where you have more cources,
say, a vehicle, or pedestrian, et cetera.
In my case, though I was just wanting to improve on my lanefining algorithm.
So, I just looked at the lane itself.
Some of the other applications also look for just free space on the road,
which I thought, well,
I don't really want my car to be driving on the opposite side of the road.
So, I really only want to know what my own lane is here.
One of the challenges that I ran into first
was in actually getting this to fully work in train correctly.
Because semantic segmentation networks
actually also use a technique that are called skip layers.
Now, skip layers can very easily be used to
essentially go from skipping entire middle section of the network,
or they could also be used just to skip between
two layers or more layers, however many you want.
Now, this is important because when you've extracted some more advanced features,
but you've also gone through max-pooling layers,
you have a lot of times losing information about
where in the image a certain thing occurred.
So, if I'm trying to classify every pixel,
it's important to have that information at the end,
and be able to draw that back.
Now, another thing that happens is when you perform backpropagation,
you need to make sure that the information is actually
going all the way through because if you get a really deep network,
backpropagation can have what's called a vanishing gradient problem,
where you're doing so much of the chain rule,
and multiplication going back.
Then it starts diminishing that gradient and, essentially,
you don't really feed in the error to those earlier layers in a really deep network.
This helps fix that problem because you
actually skip in over missing some of the multiplication in the middle,
and that backpropagation signal continues all the way back to the front of the network,.
Really interesting. Nice. Thank you.
Yeah. Thanks.